le convoi de la liberté s'apprête à
débarquer sur le vieux continent en
france un groupe facebook compte plus de
230 mille inscrits dix jours après sa
création sur twitter et télégramme aussi
à des internautes s'organisent pour
monter des convois au départ de toutes
les régions de l'hexagone en direction
de bruxelles où il espère rejoindre des
manifestants venus des quatre coins
d'europe objectif pousser les autorités
françaises et européennes à en finir
avec les restrictions sanitaires
le pass vaccinale et le pas salutaire
que l'union européenne souhaite
conserver jusqu'en 2023 au moins les
citoyens entendent récupérer leur
liberté leurs droits fondamentaux l'axé
inconditionnel aux soins à l'éducation
et à la culture le respect des valeurs
essentielles de notre constitution stop
aux sacrifices des enfants et de la
jeunesse cessons là maltraitances subies
quotidiennement le canada nous a ouvert
la voie la convergence européenne pour
nos enfants et tous les citoyens c'est
maintenant d'autres revendications
concernant le coût de la vie notamment
semblent émerger ces derniers jours à
l'image de celle portée par les gilet
jaune depuis le début de l'année 2022 le
prix du carburant est à un niveau jamais
atteint même chose pour les prix de
l'énergie c'est un convoi en partance de
toute la france pour aller rejoindre la
capitale les convois seront composés de
particulier avec leur propre véhicule
camping cars ou voitures de particuliers
il faut bien rappeler c'est important
que c'est un rassemblement qui s'annonce
pacifique et joyeux qu'est ce que le
convoi de la liberté il née à la mi
janvier au canada des centaines de
camions et de voitures ont formé un
convoi dans l'ouest du pays pour rallier
vancouver à ottawa la capitale
ce qui a mis le feu aux poudres celle
isolement de deux semaines imposé aux
non vaccinés qui franchissent la
frontière entre les etats-unis et le
canada
une décision qui s'apparente selon les
routiers shia une obligation vaccinale à
la fin du mois de janvier le cortège a
bloqué de nombreux quartiers de la
capitale menacés sur les réseaux sociaux
le premier ministre canadien et sa
famille ont dû être exfiltré et conduit
dans un lieu secret une fuite en avant
de justin trudeau qui pourrait donner
des sueurs froides à emmanuel macron sur
la toile plusieurs internautes et
personnalité politique soutienne
l'adaptation française du convoi de la
liberté
il semble bien que le château de cartes
mondial de la corruption et commencé de
s'écrouler et sa part du canada trudeau
se cache la vague va déferler sur la
france
après le canada les routiers français et
européens se mobilisent soutien au
convoi de la liberté tous à paris c'est
ce qu'on appelle un rapport de force
bien ouej les copains le pass vaccinale
ne sert à rien c'est un moyen de
surveillance les traitements précoces
existe le convoi de la liberté en france
s'organise mais ce convoi de la liberté
est loin de faire l'unanimité l'ancien
patron de charlie hebdo fois critiqué le
projet et a assuré que les routiers en
raison des déplacements inhérents à leur
profession constituer une population à
risque en période épidémique et il s'est
d'ailleurs livré à un parallèle pour le
moins hasardeux au début le sida s'est
propagée principalement par les routiers
ce n'est pas de leur faute évidemment
mais il traverse les frontières ils font
partie des vecteurs de virus s'il y en a
qui doivent se faire vacciner et avoir
un pass vaccinale cd routier abjecte
méprisante nausée cette sortie a généré
une levée de boucliers sur les réseaux
sociaux entre les pro et les anti qu'on
voit la hache de guerre est déterrée
le convoi de la liberté français
connaîtra-t-il le même succès qu'à
ottawa non disent les renseignements
territoriaux qui évoque un risque faible
de blocage en raison de l'absence de
participation des organisations
syndicales
reste à savoir maintenant si les
manifestants vont leur donner tort ou
raison